هل نفد هذا الاقتصاد الوبائي المزدهر
زخمه على الرغم من نمو الوظائف على نطاق واسع
، والجنون في سوق
الإسكان ، والمكاسب الضخمة في S P 500 العام الماضي
، يحذر العديد من الاقتصاديين والرؤساء التنفيذيين الآن من
أن الركود قد يلوح في الأفق حيث
يحاول الاحتياطي الفيدرالي ترويض
التضخم المرتفع عن طريق التنزه بقوة
أسعار الفائدة حتى رئيس بنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
نفسه يعترف بأنه من المحتمل أن يتصرف محافظو البنوك المركزية في
وقت أقرب
بعد فوات الأوان.يقول إنه كان يجب علينا التحرك في
وقت مبكر ، سنستخدم أدواتنا
وسنقوم بإنجاز ذلك الآن ،
التحدي الذي يواجه الاحتياطي الفيدرالي هو هذا التباطؤ
الاقتصاد بما يكفي للسيطرة على التضخم
ولكن ليس لدرجة أنه
يتحول إلى الركود ، إنه البحث
عن ما يسمى بالهبوط الناعم ، لكن
لن يكون من السهل أن تكون فرص الانسحاب
منخفضة للغاية
لأنهم مضطرون إلى دفع
معدل البطالة وفي الماضي عندما
ترفع معدل البطالة ،
لم تكن قادرًا على تجنب الركود الكامل
حيث أن مخاوف الركود تتزايد لدى
المستثمرين.  أسهم g
والأصول الأخرى المحفوفة بالمخاطر ، كل شيء من قطاع التكنولوجيا
إلى أسهم التجزئة إلى عملة البيتكوين قد
هبطت عوامل أخرى مثل
غزو روسيا لأوكرانيا وإغلاق 19
في الصين ، فإنهم لا
يساعدون التوقعات ، لذلك إذا انزلق الاقتصاد الأمريكي
إلى الركود فما هو الشكل الذي سيحدث؟  يتطلب
الأمر وجود مجموعة من
الاحتمالات الأبجدية ، فالمنحنى على شكل حرف V هو
أفضل سيناريو للحالة ، إنه انخفاض
حاد يتبعه انتعاش حاد في
كثير من الأحيان ينتج عن صدمة لمرة واحدة
للاقتصاد كما رأينا في
بداية الوباء
منحنى على شكل حرف U عبارة عن ركود
طويل الأمد يستغرق بضع سنوات حتى يتعافى إجمالي الناتج المحلي تمامًا
الآن والذي حدث في منتصف
السبعينيات خلال أزمة النفط وفترة
من الركود التضخمي ، ثم هناك
ركود مخيف على شكل حرف L أو ركود هوكي
وهو الأسوأ  الحالة عندما
يتحول الركود المطول إلى ركود
كامل ، فإن الكساد الكبير
هو مثال كلاسيكي ولكن بعض
الاقتصاديين يجادلون بالأزمة المالية
التي بدأت في 200  7 واستغرق ما يقرب من
ست سنوات لتحقيق الانتعاش الكامل كما التقى
بهذا التعريف على شكل حرف L ، وهناك
أيضًا w عندما يرتد الاقتصاد
سريعًا فقط لينزلق مرة أخرى إلى
الركود وأخيرًا هناك k
الآن عندما تنتعش قطاعات مختلفة من
الاقتصاد بسرعة أكبر  أكثر من الآخرين الذين
خلقوا خطين منفصلين للتعافي ،
يجادل بعض الاقتصاديين بأن هذا ما
حدث بالفعل بعد بداية الوباء
عندما كان العمال ذوو الدخل المنخفض آخر من
شعر بعودة الاقتصاد ،
وهذا كثير من الرسائل ولكن تذكر أن
الركود مجرد احتمال في هذه
المرحلة  لا يزال هذا هو الوقت الذي يتعامل فيه الاقتصاديون
بجدية شديدة ،
كنت أتحدث إلى مجموعة من
المتنبئين المحترفين في اليوم الآخر ، وقال واحدًا تلو
الآخر إنهم لا يستطيعون تذكر
بيئة حيث كان هذا غير مؤكد
عمليات الإغلاق في الصين على رأس
حرب اقتصادية هشة بالفعل في
تضخم سريع في أوروبا في الولايات المتحدة ،
لديك مقومات لعاصفة
ركود عالمي مثالي ، إنها مخاطرة وليست
مؤكدة  y لكنها مخاطرة مخيفة جدًا وهي
أن العائلات الأمريكية
بدأت تخشى بشكل متزايد